foreign
[Music]
to shoot these stunts for Mission
Impossible with Tom there are no limits
so we become a little bit more
adventurous every time
Tom's doing a sport very few people on
this planet do it's called speed flying
it's a very beautiful and delicate sport
but it also is one of the most dangerous
sports in the world while it may look
similar speed flying is not skydiving
skydiving is fairly predictable speed
flying is incredibly unpredictable
it's a very small canopy racing down the
mountains just feet off the ground these
sort of Crosswinds could put Tom in
peril
we're gonna do spirals
and we're Landing in an incredibly high
speed over 80 kilometers an hour
we've been training for a few years now
and we're always looking for what's the
most dynamic way to shoot this
foreign
coming up with the stunt is only one of
the technical challenges the other is
putting a camera in a place that you can
see where Tom is operating the speedway
you can't get close to this with a
helicopter or a drone so we had to
develop a gimbal system flying along
with Tom who had cameras hanging off of
both sides being operated in a
helicopter what's going to work is
here's you here's me this is what we
need
that's one of the things they're doing
practical action we are at the mercy of
weather
too dangerous
the wind's dropping down it's only going
to get better let's go let's go let's go
I'm ready
confirming you have pictures good
Thomas airport Thomas airborne
flying very close to rocks looks quite
beautiful
behind the scenes we were all in
absolute Terror Landing Tom had to be
flying towards the camera vehicle that
meant that Tom had to hit the exact mark
or it can end it disaster
[Music]
it is truly a one of a kind Adventure
we came to Rome to shoot a chasing
something with a lot more ambition and
unpredictability that we haven't had in
previous chases we'll be screaming
through the streets of Rome Motorcycles
Cars everything that we shot me is
completely practical we're doing it
right
it all comes down to one thing how do we
involve the audience I just want to give
them that thrill
[Music]
[Applause]
we let the city tell us the kind of
Chase it was going to be traffic in the
city is notorious and the cobblestone
streets may fall to the driving
unpredictable
best part is Tom and Haley's
they're handcuffed together
people are chasing us yes they are no
driving
for real no cheating it the key is don't
crash
foreign
[Music]
driving and drifting one-handed through
the streets of Rome that was the day I
will never forget trying to do drifts
every time you think you're going in One
Direction it's the cobblestones on the
street saying no you're not you're going
this way you gotta get rid of this car
[Applause]
tell me how to ditched the car for one
of their IMF there because
suddenly this tiny little Fiat 500 comes
out of nowhere we built this Fiat 500
so that it would be faster
[Music]
you could barely control the car it was
treacherous the Fiat that was wild some
would even say the car is possessed
I don't think we could have made a
sequence that was more difficult to
shoot if I had gone out of my way to do
it it has really amazing results
would be impossible without this crew of
an actor like Tom
right we lost them
when we started talking about this movie
in terms of a sense of adventure an
action sequence on a train was something
we'd always wanted to do
we wanted to build upon the previous
films and apply all of that knowledge to
something practical and real
and bring this train sequence to another
level
there was not a surplus of trains
available to be wrecked we had to build
the train if we wanted to destroy it
to shoot it practically it was extremely
challenging
not just to execute but also to design
all the different train cars that could
actually function on a working railroad
track
no one else in the world is doing this
level of practical filmmaking and it may
never be done again
the train sequence takes us in an
adventure that's absolutely huge we have
this big fly on the roof going 60 miles
an hour through a real Valley
I've done fight scenes but to do them on
a moving train was trial by fire that's
how Tom likes to do things
[Music]
is going to now pull me off the train
when you're hanging off a train Carriage
Tom's a great person to have beside you
not only is he Fearless he is always
looking to see how it's going to land
for the audience
[Music]
crash in the train involved multiplying
factors of difficulty you'd be chasing
the train as it goes off every single
camera they've had exactly one shot at
getting it right that's just a matter of
going off because if we do it all we
don't capture it right what's the point
everything you are seeing in this
spectacular train sequence is done to
invest the audience in these characters
Mission Impossible is the most
extraordinary Adventure franchise you've
ever seen he could only do it with a
team like this and with an actor like
Tom
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
are the sum of our choices
he cannot escape the past
Ethan this mission of yours
caused you
the world is changing
the truth is Vanishing War
it's been a long time
you've no idea the power I represents
it knows your story and How It Ends
foreign
's coming after you
his fate is written shall we write yours
too if anything happens to them there's
no place that I won't go to kill you
that you
know
[Applause]
Ethan what's your objective
what's your ultimate objective
your life will always matter more to me
than my own
none of our Lives can matter More Than
This Mission I don't accept that
[Music]
foreign